hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the key
and recurrent themes in epictetus is
philosophy that you see in his
discourses sometimes with entire
chapters devoted to that like to those
who seek preferment in Rome or how we
ought to conduct ourselves towards
tyrants is a concern about giving too
much thought giving too much of our own
emotional life and value to externals
and not just external things like you
know a chalkboard or whether the truck
goes right but specifically to other
people from a stoic perspective other
people are going to be like ourselves
because there is a common human nature
but it doesn't take all that much
experience to realize that you know
whether you're a stoic or not most
people tend not to ham it all together
as a matter of fact from a stoic
perspective you can say it's a safe bet
that most people that you're going to
encounter are badly off with respect to
the structure of their Faculty of choice
the ruling Faculty of the rational
faculty they make all sorts of mistakes
about what truly is
good and what isn't and what is you know
neutral how to evaluate things
essentially in practical reasoning so to
give ourselves over to them to make them
the criteria for our own contentment or
happiness is a fundamental mistake from
Epictetus perspective if we worry about
the expectations and the judgments of
others we are we're never going to
progress as Stoics and that includes
even Epictetus if you're in it to try to
make you know Epictetus things if you
could from beyond the grave
good job you really wouldn't be on the
right track as far as stoicism goes so
the fundamental problem with all of this
is going to be orienting ourselves by
other people which means orienting
ourselves by something that
fundamentally is not within our own
power or it is not in our own business
if you want to translate that come in
that way and so I've got a couple
particularly interesting chapters to
mention here there's there's a chapter
21 a book one which is about those who
want to be admired it's a very short
chapter and he asks this question well
who do you actually want to be admired
by and why how is that actually going to
make you happy or content if you want to
be admired by those who are particularly
great well then you'd have to have some
sort of qualities and so you probably
should put the emphasis on that's very
much similar to Aristotle's discussion
about honor in nicob McKay and ethics
book 1 where he says you know honored is
kind of arbitrary but it does point us
toward something better if we're we're
concerned about you know
but the best people think of us then we
have to strive to have something that
they can say oh yeah that's really good
in other words we need virtue
Epictetus isn't going to quit go there
it's ten easy to go to the other side
and say OD so is it the ordinary run of
the middle person the the big unwashed
mass of the public as we sometimes call
it you know Facebook Likes or things
like that that you're going to use as
your your metrics or whether you're
admired or liked or found credible you
know is it your your score in social
media you know if you're doing that
you're kind of crazy he says because you
think all those people are crazy and so
it's super crazy for you to be
subjecting your faculty of choice to
these people they don't know what's good
and bad why would you be so silly as to
trying to see generation from that now
when we look at chapter 19 of book 1 we
see a different side of this a much more
pressing side you might say he talks
about tyranny actually uses that word or
two terminals there but we could think
in terms of any sort of bully or you
know person who's trying to control us
to get something out of us to coerce us
into things and what does that victi
does he have to say about that
now the stoic quite famously would tell
the tyrant you can throw my body in the
chains but you can't chain my moral
purpose you can't change you can't chain
my faculty well the thing we could say
you know try to walk across the room and
an Epictetus could say well you know I
know I haven't chains so I'm not going
to choose to try and do something that's
not physically possible but you can't
control my inner self the thing that
really is me where my emotions lie where
my you know rationality can be the
ruling part where my desires and
aversion
and choices and all of these sorts of
things are you know not kept were there
happening that's really what I am and
you can't do much about it at all he is
by the way quite familiar with terribly
coercive techniques that can be used on
people because the ancients had quite a
few
you know quite brutal methods of torture
and a lot of ruses that they would use
to try to get information out of people
it was such an issue that by the time
that Aristotle a little bit earlier is
writing is rhetoric he has to actually
say you know what you can't really use
coerced testimony and expect it to be
any good because so many people were
using it so what do we what do we say
about dealing with tyrants first we can
understand that the tyrant himself or
herself it is acting the way that they
do in part because they see it as
reasonable but the reason why they see
it as reasonable is because they don't
really know what is reasonable there's
something off-kilter there they believe
themselves superior in some respect to
other people and then they lord it over
them they become prideful as I put here
there's many other ways of describing
this they you know become aggressive
they assume superiority in other
respects so you know the tyrant could be
somebody who's born into a good family
goes to a local restaurant and then acts
like a complete jerk to the waitstaff
because you know obviously they're
better than the waitstaff because they
don't have to wait tables themselves you
know if you're the service industries I
think you probably know this sort of
thing there's many other ways you know
you could be you could be a tyrannical
professor I've encountered a few of
those in my time it can even flip itself
on on its head so you know students who
thrive
to give you a valuation that's really
being in tyrant they think that they can
get what they want by making the other
person do something of what they're
doing it is in essence giving the other
person the proposition if you don't do
acts or if you do do acts I am going to
hurt you in some way I'm going to hurt
your body I'm going to hurt your
possessions I'm going to hurt your
position they'll go into your permanent
record
I'm going to hurt your social standing
you know I'm going to say nasty things
about you of social media so everyone
will shun you all these sorts of things
are the kinds of threats that the
tyrants made
they even threaten people's family
they'll make all sorts of things and the
effort is to try to get that person to
break to try to get their widow to be
conformed with her fact their choice
rather to that of the tyrant what it is
that the tyrant wants from them so this
is really a lack of development on the
targets part now what epictetus says is
the tyrant and the Tigers threats don't
really disturb or harm us so what does
our own judgments our own dog Mata in
the greedy our views of things are what
harm us if we think that what really
matters the most is our social standing
we make ourselves incredibly vulnerable
to tyrants and then we have to as the
saying goes go all along to get along
right or just keep our heads that we
have a lot of cliché phrases that we use
for that sort of thing so where does the
responsibility lie the tyrant is a jerk
and is acting like a jerk in part
because they think that's the reasonable
thing to do but that's a sign of how
screwed up they are but we have a choice
according to deputies about whether we
follow their line and read
today and allow more ourselves to be
sucked into it and then controlled and
coerced we don't have to see that the
tyrant and ourselves could be suffering
from incorrect views about what is and
what is what is outside of our moral
purpose our Pro racists are faculty of
choice so he says the tyrant can say I'm
going to throw you in Chains when a
chain you're lying and that victi that
says here it is go ahead
you're not chaining my moral purpose you
can do what you like you're gonna kill
me all right I'll stretch my neck out
and and willingly accept it but you
don't have any control over whether I
choose it or gulches it whether I fight
against it or accept it I no one in
charge of that I think Tina's would say
and insofar as we forget that we end up
harming ourselves now he also points out
another very important thing to keep in
mind with respect to this you know
question about making other people the
touchstone for our moral development and
for our tranquility for our happiness
for what it is that we really value he
said yes can and I put this in
parentheses to emphasize it can
partially or temporarily having another
person's favor like you know getting
invited to the parties or being told
you're a swell guy or you know a nice
write-up in the magazine about
up-and-coming entrepreneur or you know
this you know great performance review
and we got on the list of all some
things can temporarily being in another
person's favor really helped us with two
things one can it help us deal with our
real bit can being in another person's
favor make us into a better person
it certainly could make us seem like a
better person in terms of the outside
world
very shifting and we can't rely upon it
and if you you know if you want to put
this to the test go ahead and try it out
and see how long fans about you know
who's up and who's down really last
takes an incredible amount of effort to
try to stay in everybody's eyes and I'm
everybody's good side and all it takes
is a little bit of not paying attention
and you can slip back down into
obscurity in silence
well then vh1 will a couple long ten
years later and do a special on you if
you're famous enough so that's one of
the can the can seeking out the favor of
others really help us develop towards
our good or is it something that we
probably should distance ourselves from
as rational beings saying no I need to
work myself on my own structure my own
moral purpose and see this through can
it also helped us with the not real
evils that we might fear if we have a
lot of friends if we get a high social
position if the boss gives us the corner
office next to his in the c-suite is
that going to keep us from dying is
there going to keep us from suffering
disease will it even prevent us from
poverty
not necessarily it could be another
financial meltdown and then everybody's
out right so these these attempts to try
to obtain security in life from the
things that we from stoic perspective
mistakenly perceived to be evils it's
it's a doomed attempt it's going to fail
because having lots of friends or having
lots of admirers or having the ranking
of patron that's not something that can
provide us with that sort of security
even if you could rely on those people
they can't do much about the fact that
sooner or later you're going to die you
have to face up to that
taking a little bit further when
everyplace yourself and your sense of
what's what's worthy and what's valuable
into the arena of other people's
opinions you're asking for trouble
because those opinions are not
necessarily what they even do think and
they're not gonna remain constant for
long
and you're inevitably going to feel let
down and then upset and all sorts of
other negative emotions so from a stoic
perspective you know you don't want to
be subject to other people I have to say
one of the thing when he's talking about
about this being subject to other people
he doesn't mean that you shouldn't have
a job description or that you you know
shouldn't fit into some hierarchy
somewhere or that you should never take
any anybody else's advice or
instructions or anything like that but
you should evaluate what sort of
emotional price you are setting yourself
up to pay by you know focusing how those
other people see is something that you
do not have control over you have some
control over what we might call
necessary conditions so if you want
people to like you you actually have to
be a fairly likable person and behaves
them if you're going around kicking
everybody nobody's I don't think you
except maybe some Club of kickers you
know on some website but even if you do
that you don't control whether they will
have a positive reaction to you or not
you can be the best person ever and
constantly doing good and people can
still look at you and say I don't like
that guy so that's not where we want to
put our emphasis instead we want to
focus on what actually is in our power
and that is what falls into the scope of
our moral purpose